So love Parness love partners is the indicted
henchman of Trump's lawyer, Rudy Giuliani.
He has already said, uh, I will testify under
oath that Devin Nunez was flying to Europe
and trying to push Ukrainian officials to
find or to claim to have dirt on Biden.
Lev Parness has now reportedly delivered recordings
of Trump and Giuliani to the house intelligence
committee that's running the impeachment hearings,
depending on what is on those recordings.
This may be the blockbuster.
So far of this entire story.
These are audio and video recordings as well
as photographs and these include Donald Trump
and Rudy Giuliani.
We don't yet know what is on the recordings,
but what is increasingly clear is that Lev
Parness is not the type of guy to mess with,
especially after he has also implicated Devin
Nunez personally in being part of the round
the world trips seeking dirt on Joe Biden
on taxpayer dollars.
By the way, as we already discussed, really
it seems that people like love Parness and
Igor Fruman are the types of people it's best
not to associate with at all because they
might be helping Rudy Giuliani do his stuff
for Donald Trump at first, but these are not
dumb people and they were collecting recordings
and at least as far as love Parness goes,
Igor Fruman is actually not cooperated at
all.
Love Parness seems ready to spill the beans
and has already turned over audio visual recordings
involving Donald Trump and Rudy Giuliani.
I think it was James call me that said, Oh
Lordy, there are tapes.
This is potentially huge and this feels again
like history repeating itself.
Going back to Nixon in the 1970s where a whole
bunch of stuff happened, a whole bunch of
allegations and assertions were made and then
at some point into the scandal it was learned.
There are recordings and the recordings of
course are very, very damaging in many of
these cases.
Now, I got an email yesterday over the weekend
saying, David, don't you think that Russians
have the oval office bugged at this point?
Trump had that Russian spy recruiter Sergei
Kislyak in the oval office.
We have to believe Donald Trump is under surveillance
by the Russians.
Now don't we?
I don't know the answer.
Nothing would surprise me at this point.
But as far as these tapes go, if Trump is
on the tapes, we can only assume it's not
good for him because consider how self incriminating
Donald Trump is in public, right?
Donald Trump doesn't even have the sense or
the ability to avoid self-incrimination in
public.
Later I'll get to his latest Fox news interview,
which is, which is a doozy and he does a lot
of self-incrimination.
If you understand how useless and clueless,
uh, Trump is when it comes to not self incriminating,
when he knows that he's in public.
Imagine what this guy says in private and
people who are behind the scenes who were
behind the scenes on his reality show.
The apprentice have talked about this, and
I'm not even talking about the likely use
of racial slurs, which Trump is accused of
behind the scenes that the apprentice, more
likely the tapes could be of Trump and conversations
which clearly indicate he knows people.
He has since claimed not to know.
There could be tapes of Trump using language
that makes it obvious that he specifically
wanted a quid pro quo bribery, extortion,
whatever.
Uh, the tapes could be anything and I can't
imagine that they are exculpatory in nature.
So we'll, we will see what comes of these
tapes that have some representatives, uh,
intelligence committee reportedly just working
through the tapes right now.
My prediction is number one, this is not going
to be a particularly good week for Devin Nunez.
And if anything, the Thanksgiving holiday
will help them to take attention away from
this absolutely disastrous news.
And it's also important to remember just as
a general thing when we are looking at this
issue of tapes and recordings and everything
else, Trump thinks that the things he says
in private are exculpatory.
So, for example, last week when Gordon Sunland
testified, um, on a phone call, Donald Trump
said, I don't want a quid pro quo.
And then Donald Trump heard that and said,
Hey, that sounds great.
That makes me sound innocent.
And he came out and with the helicopter weight
blades whirring he said, here's what I told
Sunland on the phone.
I don't want a quid pro quo.
And then any common sense thinker would say,
wait a second.
There was no quid pro quo.
Why are you calling your ambassador and saying,
I definitely don't want a quid pro quo.
This is like the example I gave last week,
all co I call my girlfriend and tell her,
Hey, pick up a few things at the grocery store
and listen, don't shoplift.
Don't go.
I don't want you shoplifting.
I don't want you stealing this stuff.
Unless there was reason to think that that
would happen, you wouldn't even bring that
up.
And of course we know that now the timing
of Donald Trump saying this to Gordon Sutherland
was because he already knew that allegations
of quid pro quo were growing.
It doesn't help his case whatsoever.
He doesn't even realize it.
And after the break, we're actually going
to get to video, which once again this is
just a gong show, bizarre interview on Fox
news where I believe Trump thinks he is making
himself look innocent and he has actually
completely self incriminated that's coming
up later.
Make sure that you are signed up on the David
Pakman show newsletter, black Friday.
This Friday we will have an email blast going
out with an amazing membership discount.
If you've been sort of thinking about becoming
a David Pakman show member and supporting
independent media, this Friday will be a good
day to do it.
We'll have an email going out in the early
afternoon with a coupon code to be notified
of that coupon code.
Simply get on our newsletter@davidpakman.com
let me know what you think about the tape
on Twitter at [inaudible],